Go the physics and engineering sections of a technical schools library, and
you'll see a huge amount of information on a wide variety of phenomena. Beyond
drag, lift and stretch there are many other properties we could simulate.
Friction, applied force, flow, elasticity, tension, normal force, turbulence,
spring force, heat transfer, gravity, trust and so forth. Computing these is
done by what's called a dynamic solver. What you're seeing on the screen now
are a number of different simulations done for all sorts of phenomenon. A few
of these are computed at interactive speeds, some are created offline. In
either case, the rendering is separate from the physical computations.
Typically, the way solvers work is that a tiny timestep is chosen for the
simulation, often smaller than the time represented by the frame. The effect of
forces in the scene are computed for this sliver of time and objects are
modified. This process is done again and again, time slice by time slice. Small
steps help avoid various types of errors. The area of physical simulation is
wide ranging and users can have different goals. An engineer or scientist may
be making a visualization of a particular process and so the simulator is
aiming to be as realistic and true to the physical world as possible. If
interactive speeds are not needed, then time slices can be exceedingly small,
and mostly dependent on how much compute time the user wants to spend. The
other major area that uses simulation, is for generating what I call plausible
animations. These animations are not required to be physically correct. Rather
their goal is to look reasonable to the viewer. Just as we don't pick up on
reflection maps not having perfect correct reflections, there are plenty of
errors we don't notice or can rationalize away. Though using physical
principles for the creation of effects normally gives the most realistic
results, for interactive rendering we often have to make significant
simplifications. There are also simulators for phenomena that are not based on
physics. For example, flocks of birds in flight, traffic in a city, and crowds
of people walking inside a building are all systems that can be simulated with
some basic rules. The artist can also guide the simulation as desired, perhaps
having characters run towards a particular location and jostle for position.